el inicio del camino hacia la paz Cuando
se van a cumplir dos años del conflicto
en Etiopía tanto el gobierno etíope como
Los Rebeldes de tigre se encuentran en
Sudáfrica para iniciar las negociaciones
hospiciadas por la unión africana y
marcadas por el secretismo un diálogo
que para el portavoz de las fuerzas
tigriñas pasa por el cese de la
hostilidades militares la delegación del
gobierno de tigre y para las
conversaciones de paz dirigidas por la
unión africana acaba de llegar a
Sudáfrica urgente cese inmediato de la
hostilidades acceso humanitarios sin
restricciones y retirada de las fuerzas
de litera No puede haber una solución
militar la guerra de larga Data entre el
Gobierno Federal de addisabeva con la
ayuda de las fuerzas de la vecina
eritrea y el frente popular de
liberación de tigre comenzó el 4 de
noviembre de 2020 tras una tregua de
cinco meses el pasado 24 de agosto se
recrudecieron los ataques y el cruce de
acusaciones poniendo en vilo las
negociaciones para encontrar una salida
pacífica al conflicto y en la medida en
que hayan podido llegar a ese acuerdo es
importante y es probable que veamos un
alto al en los próximos días dado a los
intentos anteriores no solo en Etiopía
sino en otros procesos similares una
cosa que siempre se ha dejado de lado es
que no han sido tan inclusivos como
deberían ser y por lo tanto terminaron
invalidando cualquier acuerdo se estima
que entre 300.000 y 600.000 personas han
muerto hay más de 2 millones de
desplazados así como una grave
emergencia humanitaria en La Norteña
región separatista de tigre por lo que
los organismos como Naciones Unidas y la
Unión Europea están presionando a las
autoridades de etíopes para lograr un
acuerdo inmediato